every actor knows that a memorable
character is a collaboration with a lot
of different people especially with this
next group of nominees without the
genius contributions of makeup artists
and hairstylists we would lose ourselves
in classic films like The Godfather
Elephant Man Raging Bull Magic Mike to
think about it but let's be honest they
deserve an award just for putting up
with us actors not to mention the
prosthetics the wigs the occasional
Merkin if you happen to be laughing
please explain it to the person next to
you and if you aren't google it here are
the nominees for achievement and makeup
and hairstyling
Mad Max fury road leslie van der waals
elka wardega and Damien Martyn the 100
year old man who climbed out the window
and disappeared Luther lotion and ever
fun bar the revenant
Shawn Greg Duncan Jarmon and Robert pan
Dini
and the Oscar goes to Mad Max fury road
elka wardega I'm Damian Martin
well amazing you can pop the Cork's at
high and we're running home gold
fantastic thank you very much to the
Academy thank you very much to Warner
Brothers thank you to all our fantastic
crew cross the globe there were many of
them as Colin said a lot of it's already
been said by Jenny and Colin but you
know once again we want to thank George
who is you know with his vision yeah his
vision and thank you for taking us all
along you're amazing George we love you
I just like to thank my parents and my
beautiful one week old today daughter
Elvira and her beautiful mother Heather
yeah and the last report is back home
all that colleagues thank you so much
thank you